hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the Asian Championship
2018 it's a game between way ye and
Alireza furiosa
I don't think neither of them need any
introduction so I suggest we just go on
with the game and I I'm waiting for some
for books to arrive I order for books
about Jose bro kappa blanka that i will
be using in my kappa blanka saga as that
is our next big series until that
arrives we're just gonna check up on
some of the other games from your
suggestions maybe a couple more games
from alpha zero and as the london chess
classic has finished we will check up on
the the sun way serious tournament that
is currently being played the fifth
edition but this game like we said the
asian championship I don't know if
you've seen wayy one that's tournament
so an excellent achievement for for for
the Chinese Grandmaster but this game
it's really wild it features the
Sicilian defense but a very rare
variation where all the for bishops get
fianchetto so it's a very nice line and
I'm sure you're going to enjoy it as
it's really just a wild game so without
further ado let's dive straight into it
wayyyyy has the white pieces and he
opens with E 4 we have C 5 like we said
the Sicilian defense Knight to c3 and d6
sorry about that with Knight G 2 e 2 so
we start off as the closed Sicilian but
Knight to c6 and now d4 nonetheless we
have captures captures and Knight to f6
we've transposed into the open classical
variation of the Sicilian and here you
could go Bishop to c4 into the source
and attack you to go Bishop g5 into the
Rickster rouser but here we have a g3
the fiend kept a variation way he
prepares the fiend cut out the light
square bishop and black does the same we
have g6 now and now Knight captures on
c6 you might think it's odd you know
capturing like this allowing black
strength in the center but if you start
the Bishop to g2 then black and always
capture in the center and after Queen
captures Bishop g7 you will always have
to lose a tempo to go back with the
Queen as you don't want all our
distension so capturing
tonight first B captures on c6 and only
now Bishop to g2
so now you you're not gonna be losing
any Tempe by retreating with the Queen
but you have strengthened black center
and also given black as a semi-open B
file but it's not really a problem as
white also plans to play B 3 so the rook
on unbe it is not gonna be that that big
of a deal
Bishop to b7 by black here at this
position has been played many times
before and here Bishop to g4 was played
Bishop to d7 was played Bishop to g7 but
better up to b7 is a new move and
already from move 7 we have a completely
new game on the board we have b3 as
prepared Bishop to g7 Bishop to b2 we
have castles castles and now comes the
Queen to c8 quinta c7 seems a bit more
bit more natural developing the Queen
allowing the rooks to be connected but
Ali Reza is I believe 15 years old he's
already a 2600 Grandmaster so if he goes
Queen to c8 it I guess it's definitely
playable it still protects the bishop
here so if the position opens up the
Queen will be guarding the bishop you
will be supporting the c5 pawn and also
you will you will make room for this
rook tables so you can enter the game
Queen to d2 way Enoch develops the Queen
connects rooks and now rook to d8 and
eyes developing move for black also
places the rook on the same file as
White Queen rook a to d1 simply
developing and now comes c5 a very nice
move that releases the bishop now it
becomes active but also kind of keeps an
eye on the d4 square so perhaps the
black could have some ideas maybe maybe
Knight d7 to e5 to c6 to d4 that's a lot
of moves with the knight but if white
wants to prevent it too what will also
make have to make some concessions but
okay rook after a 1 developing the final
piece and now you could go something
like Knight to d7 or Knights the e8 so
the bishop would also keep an eye on d5
square as white definitely once the sort
push 'if I've at some point point being
that eastex was played in the game and
he
we played e5 and now already you can see
that if the knight was on D seven or
eight if I would not be possible and we
would have to find some different plan
because here you can just go into
trading as after captures captures
captures and captures the bishop on b7
is hanging black loses the bishop and
it's all over white is up a piece
completely winning so here
Knights the g4 was played perhaps a
better move was was a bit more passive
nice to the e8 simply keeping an eye on
the d6 pawn and after the light for
bishops are exchanged f4 strengthening
in the center but then black even has
the option of playing d5 and here black
would be perfectly fine but Alireza went
for a different land instead of 98 he
went for an ID g4 thinking okay I will
either play d5 now if white it doesn't
react or if white captures I'm gonna
have a very strong attack but wayy
calculates precisely
he plays each character son d6 he
snatches the pawn and now comes a bishop
to d4 okay alga Reza's SEC refines the
pawn but now he has a very strong attack
against the DF to pawn also there's a
lot of tension here so we capture some
b7 we have captures captures and now how
do you prevent bishop or Knight captures
this is the positional eraser saw but he
missed one move from way if you simply
defend the pawn rook F e1 then 95 is
deadly there's a very little white can
do against Knight f3 check your already
threatening to win the Queen and with
the the black Queen on this diagonal you
know the White King has a very few
squares to go to if you just do nothing
then Knight of 3 will also perhaps lead
to checkmate after something like 93
check night here and maybe maybe Queen
to g2 a lot of possible ideas here so
way he has one move that other is
overlooked but it's basically the only
move white can plate you know retain the
edge in this position so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find how
to continue this this game from White's
perspective I will give you a couple of
seconds as usual so for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an X
attacker and for those of you who just
wanna enjoy the show in 94 is the move
seems reasonable you're defending the f2
pawn you're blocking the Queen or over
this diagonal but you are sacrificing a
piece here so Bishop captures on b2 was
played but there is nothing better and
here ye continues with c3 now the bishop
is under attack the only way to protect
the bishop is a Bishop to a3 bunch of to
a3 is played here and now comes Queen to
f4 attacking the knight here so you're
either forcing the black black to move
the knight but black doesn't really have
any squares to move to you can go f6 you
can go h6 the queen is covering h6 you
can go 95 so all you can do is protect
the knight by either f5 or h5 the
strongest defense here would perhaps be
king to g7 but even here after you give
back the piece Queen captures you can go
f5 attack the knight but then we go into
Knight captures on c5 attacking the
black Queen and after Bishop captures
you will go Queen to f4 and now you're
threatening Queen e5 check winning the
Bishop on c5 and if you protect the
bishop by something like Bishop to b6
then rook captures on e6 is coming and
after you eliminate this point and get
the rook into the game then even rook to
e7 check will be an idea Quinn will be
able to come to h6 and black costume get
to check made it so it will be a very
difficult position for black so holidays
are opts for a different choice not King
g7 but rather f5 immediately so the
knight is protected and also baiis night
and on e4 is under attack Knight to g5
now there's nothing you can do to
protect these exponents now it's
attacked twice by both the night and and
and the rook and if you play something
like e 5 which seems like it could be
played you know which attacks the Queen
forces the Queen to go back but Queen
the c-4 opening up this diagonal is just
too bad for black there there's no point
in allowing it after you move it first
to kick in the night with h3 Knight goes
back and then you can even even go
Knight to f7 check you can just
here the rock is coming to e7 it's it
will be over quickly for black so
allegorize at rice c4
you've sacrifice but as long as your
Bishop is stuck here on a3 you're you're
not really up a piece so c4 trying to
activate it this Bishop at least somehow
perhaps a Bishop to c5 to attack the f2
point would be nice and the way you can
proceed by going Knight captures an e6
but first things first
not allowing this Bishop to come back
into the game b4 ala days a tries to
free the bishop however possible we have
to be to going after the c3 pawn and
only now does we capture on e6 Knight
captures on e6 so what do you play here
you can really save the rook if you play
something like Ruby 7 you get 95 again
the Queen and rook are under attack if
you go something like rook e8 then d7 is
coming and again you're either gonna
lose the rook or you're gonna move the
rook and then allow the eight wood Queen
and then after captures you can yeah
you're gonna lose the game but you can
even you know get a nice checkmate such
as this one but okay after Knight
captures and he sits with be commercial
Catherine's on c3 going after the rook
anyone and now Knight captures and e8
attacking the Queen Queen - Queen to b5
and now you might think okay I was a
piece now I just gave up a look so white
only is up in exchange he has a look for
but I have a very strong dark square
Bishop butches a very strong attacking
piece but also a very strong defender
but here ye plays a4 and now black is in
real trouble
you can't capture because you allow
Queen to c4 check and now black will
soon get checkmate it and also if you
capture the b4 pawn then you allow the
rook to come to e8 as the Queen is no
longer guarding d8 square
after King moves then comes 96 check
you're gonna lose the rockin a8 and
everything falls apart so all the rest
here tried Knight captures on f2 which
the idea of Knight to h3 check winning
the Queen but we doesn't mind 8 captures
on b5 we have nice to h3 check and here
we simply
King to f1 and it was in this position
that ali reza resigned the game not not
playing king g2 allowing the Queen the
Knights to capture the Queen with check
because here with the best play for
example Knight captures an f4 as you do
have to you know grab the Queen rook to
e8 with check is coming and after the
King moves simply G captures on f4 and
now you're simply up a whole rook also
night II 6 check is the threat capturing
the other look as well and the black
would have very little to offer here
resistance wise so yeah after this King
to f1 holidays are resigned the game and
a wonderful victory for wayyy
who not only created this beautiful gem
but also when they won the entire Asian
Championship 2018 sir it's very
interesting where were did everything go
wrong for black most likely most likely
since since not maybe not allowing e5
although perhaps instead of e6 maybe
just going 98 or 97 taking control of d5
square not allowing g5 would make it
easier for black but even here after e5
yeah 94 94 most likely where things have
taken the turn for the worst but but
still what like we said with wooden ID 8
it would still be possible but I'll
guess I decided to go for the active
approach not for the passive and you
know he should be commended for that for
for active play and for allowing us to
enjoy chess you know on such a high
level with such beautiful moves but yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I also as you can see up in the left
corner there is some new merch available
so basically here you can check out
these are basically the two designs that
I have now there are new I'm also going
to add some of them knew it we have the
one I am an excellent subscriber and the
one just here to enjoy the show so there
are a couple of you know t-shirts
hoodies and whatnot if you are
interested in such things but yeah the
link will be in the description below so
feel free to check it out I would also
like to thank Doug was rife Evan Bercy
Sir John Petrovich Stefan Milla and
don't
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
video see or think all for watching and
I will see you soon with some more games
from your suggestions more alpha0 games
and until I receive my books on kappa
blanka we're gonna start the Arbit next
big series I think y'all and I will see
you soon